the National Football League it's the
most popular sports league in the US and
brings people together over food family
fun love of country and now we're gonna
go to a troubling new study about the
risk of brain injury in football Zico
Elliott suspended without pay for
allegations of domestic violence Colin
Kaepernick is taking his collusion case
against the NFL to trial and one of the
many NFL issues that doesn't get as much
coverage is the sexual harassment and
overall exploitation of the game's
cheerleaders Washington Redskins
cheerleaders on this 2013 trip tell NBC
News they felt sexually exploited hey
guys it's omar and this sunday we're
talking about how the NFL has been
mistreating its cheerleaders for decades
and how some cheerleaders are starting
to fight back but before we get into it
if you like topics like this hit that
subscribe button well thank you clearly
you're not only a sport it's an art and
I think that's why I fell in love with
it it's expressing yourself through
movement and it's performing and making
other people happy and that's why I love
it so much
that's Bailey Davis former cheerleader
with the New Orleans Saints after three
years of being on the team she was fired
by the Saints for posting a photo of
herself in a one-piece outfit on her
Instagram page the team said that her
posts violated their rules that
cheerleaders not appear nude semi nude
or in lingerie it just didn't make sense
to me that they could promote me however
they wanted to but when I did it it was
seen as inappropriate and made me a bad
representation of the team I didn't
really understand that they could post
pictures of me and my uniform which is a
two-piece and low-cut but the bodysuit
was inappropriate
they also alleged without proof that
Davis attended a party where a player
from the organization was present
something that would also violate team
rules and they told me that if
cheerleaders name even came out of the
football players mouth she would be
fired and that's when I realized wow the
players don't have this role at all
Davis and her lawyer have since filed a
federal complaint against the NFL and
the Saints on the basis of gender
discrimination arguing that the no
contact rule between cheerleaders and
players should go both ways
if
were to remain the first thing to do
that is absolutely free of the NFL is to
change the rules have them equal have us
not feel like we're the ones having to
protect ourselves from the football
players so don't put it completely on us
and our job shouldn't ride on whether a
football player is trying to contact us
or not but even though this might seem
like an open-and-shut case it's not the
NFL's been able to argue on numerous
occasions which we'll get to that
cheerleaders are not instruct employees
and that gender discrimination rules
only apply to NFL personnel a title that
Davis and her lawyer argue also applies
to her okay
before I continue telling you about
Davis let's contextualize cheerleading a
bit to figure out how we got to this
point organize cheerleading as a
profession goes back to the 1890s and
was a male-dominated activity and female
cheerleaders don't arrive on the scene
until the 1940s as men were being
drafted and sent off to serve in World
War two oh and some famous male
cheerleaders of the past
Dwight D Eisenhower Mitt Romney George W
Bush w did a whole lot of cheering for
warden e checks out
the NFL introduced professional
cheerleading in the 1950s for the then
Baltimore Colts and the cheerleaders
wore noticeably more modest uniforms it
wasn't until the 1970s that NFL
cheerleader uniforms changed to what we
know today the Dallas Cowboys introduced
new uniforms that caught America's
attention especially after the 1972
Super Bowl where the cheer squad
performed dance routines as opposed to
their usual acrobatics but since then
criticism that NFL cheerleaders are used
as props for AH going has been a
consistent agreements leveled against
the league
Nancy armor is a sports columnist for
USA Today and has reported on this
ongoing story I think the problem with
professional cheerleading is in a lot of
ways it's not cheerleading it's it's
basically treating women as objects if
you look at cheerleading in college it's
much more of an athletic endeavor a
sport it's open to men and women and
that's not the case with professional
cheerleaders and unfortunately that
leads to abuses of the women by the
people who are employing them not only
do they have to deal with fans
AAG lling them and scrutinizing their
appearance they had to deal with
scrutiny from NFL teams themselves the
majority of NFL teams have weight
restrictions for their cheerleaders
where they have to stay within a certain
weight level and are forbidden from
gaining even if you
pounds of course this not only has to do
with their appearance on the field but
also on the wildly popular cheerleader
calendars one example of this is the
terribly named Washington Redskins who
flew their cheerleaders to Costa Rica
for a calendar shoot in 2013 during the
shoot some cheerleaders reported they
were required to stand around topless
even though there wouldn't be any nudity
in the calendar while others stood
around with only body paint to cover
them but it gets even worse
the cheerleaders had to deal with
spectators from the Redskins fan base
who had been invited to attend the photo
shoot by having cheerleaders in their
current form in these sexed-up
objects on the sidelines that have
really no other role or no other purpose
than to be Ahnold by by fans the NFL is
telling women we really don't care about
you we want your money but you as people
you as employees we don't really care
about you Davis also experienced a lot
of rules and restrictions around her
appearance at the games and even at
practice our contract was very strict as
far as appearance goes we always had to
have our nails manicured and done either
nude or French tip we always had to have
full face gameday makeup that was for
appearances
obviously game day and practice we
always had to have her hair done we
always had to have a spray tan and all
that we had to pay for ourselves but
Davis also experienced numerous episodes
of full-on sexual harassment
while trying to sell cheerleader
calendars to fans at the game and in
order for Bailey to cheer on the field
she had to sell a minimum number of
these calendars in massive crowds that
often led to uncomfortable situations
they would say rude sexual comments I've
had my butt cried before and it is a
very shameful feeling and you feel like
it's your fault and there was one
instance where a fan pulled a calendar
out of my hand and he immediately
flipped to my month in the subject
calendar
and he made just a simple sexual comment
about my body and that was kind of my
breaking point
Davis will use that to prevent sexual
harassment cheerleaders need protection
in these situations just as the players
receive protection when they're in
public don't have us up on a pedestal as
celebrities and in these beautiful
uniforms and then throw us out into the
crowd with no protection having fans be
able to speak to us however they want
and touch us if they want that's just
completely ridiculous and then there's
wages while some players are making
millions if not hundreds of millions of
dollars cheerleaders aren't even making
minimum wage in 2014 the now Las Vegas
found Oakland Raiders settle the lawsuit
where they were accused of only paying
their cheerleaders five dollars an hour
when minimum wage in California at the
time was $8 an hour and that same year
the Buffalo Bills disbanded their
cheerleading squad after five former
members filed a lawsuit alleging they
had gone unpaid for hours they had
worked and Nancy Armour believes this is
further evidence that the
multibillion-dollar NFL doesn't value
these women if you are contending that
these women are valued employees that
they're an important part of the message
that you send they're an important part
of your team's community then their pay
should reflect that it should be more
than you know minimum wage or or
whatever it is that they get it
compensate them fairly so in the wake of
the me2 movement with open conversations
about sexual misconduct and creating
safer environments for women why have
the NFL and its clubs been so slow to
enact better pay and create a safer
environment for the cheerleaders the
questions about cheerleaders and kind of
the grousing about them has been going
on for years but I think women are
finally saying no you know what this
isn't this is not fair this is not
acceptable
and I'm not going to take it anymore
despite the slow response the NFL has
agreed to hold meetings with Davis and
her lawyer to address unfair pay and
discuss creating safer environments for
cheerleaders but many remain skeptical
about how far the league is willing to
go to bring that change especially when
they're so hesitant about making change
in general cheerleader rules are set by
each team so the league can only do so
much but the league can send a very
important message
this is appropriate this is not and we
really think that you should conform to
be more appropriate set up rules so what
can change well some think the
reintroduction of men inside NFL
cheerleading squads could change the
pervasive climate of sexual harassment
both the Los Angeles Rams and New
Orleans Saints Davis's former team have
introduced men as part of their upcoming
cheerleading squads Nancy Armour thinks
it's not necessarily a matter of
including men on cheerleading squads and
more about NFL ownership I'm not sure if
the NFL will ever get rid of
cheerleading altogether I think it's
ingrained in the sport and I think there
are unfortunately too many people who
think that it's necessary to objectify
women as part of the entertainment I
think within the next hopefully five
years cheerleaders will look different
they will be treated differently and
there will be a different attitude about
what they do hey guys I hope you enjoyed
the video let us know in the comments
what other sports stories you'd like us
to cover and don't forget to Like share
and subscribe